shout out to powerful chess
maybe the raid will bring me more power
anyway
it doesn't get easier so if you're just
joining i'm playing the the winter
marathon
i'm in 15th place um
what is this oh is this my medal
oh this is i'm playing mama diara of
what i'm playing mamadiarov
mama diaries plays
interesting alassa rosenstream for the
night owls
uh oh thanks for that gigahertz
i'm playing mamadirov he's like world
number top 20 maybe
i played him once actually in the the
first ever
season of the pro chess league he sacked
four pawns and then crushed me
good player
okay so idea bishop g3
as maybe one of the strongest ever
players i've played on leachates
apart from magnus
okay i'm gonna play positionally
um
go for this move maybe eventually c4
i'm not sure how much i'm getting from
this
takes world number eight
oh thanks for making me
making me at ease with that
i don't know what to do here his mind is
so solid
24-hour marathon happy birthday
oh thanks for that my birthday is not
right now
unfortunately
so i'm preventing bishop d7 and rook t8
yeah thanks for that erica amy
i'm berenson chess putting me at ease
so bishop b7 i have queen d6 upon might
be weak
um we're gonna go for the queen trade
rook c6 maybe
i might regret this
or i might not i don't know so there's a
line here
here it takes takes takes and then rook
here with counter play
it's all about getting counter play
that's a good move
i'm just losing a pawn
but we might get some optical bishop
situation
[Music]
so there's some chances of hope
survival and this is going to be really
unpleasant to play though
we'll see what happens
it's not plunder i don't want to make it
easy for him
oh i want to make it difficult
uh how to do this bishop
yeah my time the rook is tied down
bring the king in
to really watch my time
thanks aaron cell gifting a sub
there's a funny line h4 bishop e7
threading made in one
i win the pawn fighting this pawn now
let's go and just beat the world number
eight let's go
from a worse end game too somehow i won
all the pawns
that was nice
yeah it wasn't it's a type of position
it's not easy to
like make progress for black and then at
some point he kind of over pushed but
okay that was nice nice victory that was
our first game
you were so good oh i was nervous
towards end there because i was low on
time but
win bits the position was difficult i
was just worse
probably around here because the two
bishops and his pawns are so good and he
has extra half open file
but it worked out in the end
let's go thank you compact buffalo and
richter's neighbor